it's moses mooley's job to look after
the crews of abandoned ships
he took us to one the mv jannan that's
moored off kenya's coast
one and a half years ago it unloaded a
cargo of construction materials
here at the port of mombasa and it's
been in this channel ever since
waiting for instructions from its
lebanese owners
that the syrian crew says never came
the only way to meet them is by climbing
on board
since they can't leave the ship
the situation that you've had here
normal situation in jersey
many many many situations like just our
team yeah
the ship's crew haven't been paid since
months before it was abandoned the port
city of mombasa
is just there it's only about a
kilometer away so close
but yet so far for the sailors stuck on
board
covert restrictions and immigration
rules mean they can't go on the land
plus if they abandon the ship they risk
losing the wages that they're owed in
some cases
up to three years and so they're
confined within the decks of the ship
which they say have come to feel like a
prison
faris sajuani the ship's cook sailed
with it to turkey
romania and russia before getting
stranded here
he has a young child back home in syria
nobody feels what i feel i'm stuck here
i wish the owner could feel what we feel
if his children were here he would know
what we feel i have been away from my
family for three years
they've been confined in these cabins as
they wait for a resolution
and they're not alone around 6 000
seafarers face the same problem
on hundreds of ships abandoned by their
owners
the crew here has depended on food and
water
from a charity called mission to
seafarers brought regularly by moses
he says ship's owners try to push
abandoned crews to their limit
they wanted to cause a crisis to the
seafarer they want the seafarers to get
tired and leave the ship
so that they don't pay the salary areas
some of the crew their wives left them
because
life has to continue i would like to
term it as a modern slavery
abandoned cargos can be a problem too
it was an abandoned ship's cargo that
caused a devastating explosion
in lebanon's capital beirut last year
the crew of mv jannan hope their ordeal
will soon be over
a court in mombasa has ordered the ship
to be sold an auction took place
last week you stay for nothing just no
good
but now with some light and
some sunlight waiting order from the
court we take money
we say our goodbyes and leave the crew
waiting and hoping that whoever won the
auction will pay
up and if that happens they'll soon be
leaving too
and finally flying home but
thousands more like them around the
world are still going
nowhere malcolm webb al jazeera
mombasa kenya so
how can sailors protect themselves from
getting stuck on abandoned ships
well maritime organizations suggest they
should find out as much information as
they can about the company and the
vessel they'll be joining before they
take
the assignment if sailors are in danger
of abandonment
and if their ship owner does not respond
they are advised to contact
the insurance company under maritime
labor laws ship owners
must have insurance to assist seafarers
if they're abandoned
they also are expected to provide the
name and contact details
of the insurer frederick kenny
is the director of legal affairs at the
international maritime organization he's
also
the chair of the secretary general's
seafarers crisis action
team he joins us by skype from london
good to have you with us so first of all
can we clarify the situation
are these people unable to leave
the ships because of legal
considerations because of covert
restrictions
or is it more a case of they don't want
to leave the ships because
they want to get their salaries first
they don't want to risk losing
years and months of salaries
well the uh problem of uh seafarer
abandonment is a historical one it's
been going on for many years and the
causes
are varied usually financial with the
company they're just unable to pay their
bills including
the seafarer's wages and the seafarers
don't want to leave
in many cases without their wages which
is why
the insurance regime went into effect
in 2017. however what we've seen is
with the insurance regime going into
effect we saw a big spike
in abandonment cases the pandemic
has and the travel restrictions have
only
added to that issue we've
last year the imo and the international
labor organization
ilo saw a nearly doubling of the
abandonment cases reported
were on track for another record year uh
and the pandemic has definitely
contributed
to that for a number of different
reasons
why can't the the crew leave the ship
then and
pursue the owners legally for their
salaries why have they got to remain on
these ships it seems from what some of
them are saying they feel they've got to
remain on these ships if they physically
get off them they lose the money
well it's uh it becomes an issue of
jurisdiction for them if
if you have a seafarer that's in uh
an indian or filipino seafarer that's on
a ship that's been abandoned in africa
it becomes much more difficult for them
to gain access to the courts now
there are possibilities for them to get
legal assistance within the country
that has jurisdiction over the ship but
that can often be difficult uh
and seafarers i think are wary of that
they would rather have the money in hand
so how are they likely to get the money
in hand even if the ships are sold
are the new owners under some kind of
obligation
to pay them anything for past years of
of salaries
well normally uh if the seafarers can
can file a lien within the
the court system uh the new owners would
be responsible
for uh for uh extinguishing those liens
prior to taking possession of the ship
uh
the international transport workers
federation the
the itf the imo and the ilo do work
uh in individual cases to
get that kind of resolution so that the
second
so let me jump in there if it's a matter
of filing a lien in a court
can they do that from their homes do
they need to file that lien in court
while they're still physically on the
ship
uh they don't necessarily have to do it
but uh
in many cases i think seafarers feel
they'll lose the ability to assert that
lien once they leave
interesting all right thank you so much
for explaining the situation to us
sure certainly